this is a book of
imaginary history chronicling the
targaryen
kings of westeros it provides a context
and a background for
everything that happens in a in a song
of ice and fire and it's uh
not actually written by me it's written
by archmaester gildane
of the citadel of old town who's a a
very distinguished scholar but also a
somewhat idiosyncratic and crotchety old
man who has strong opinions on the
historical figures he's writing about so
some of his uh
views may creep into the text i don't
vouch for its authenticity the
targaryens were people
they were good ones there were bad ones
some of them were mad
they were all a product of generations
of incest
you get people of extraordinary ability
and extraordinary physical beauty which
is a targaryen hallmark they had
certain physical attributes like purple
eyes and silver gold hair that was
much prized and was considered you know
more beautiful than the run of normal
men
but you also get mad men or people who
are troubled in one way or another
they were not gods they were they were
people but they were
people with a very particular heritage
and
very particular abilities that could be
both
very good and very bad plus it has
dragons
has a lot of dragons at least up through
aegon the third
when we realized that game of thrones
the tv show was winding down
but there might be successor tv shows
i said to my publishers well
we want to we've always been talking
about doing this
history book which i was calling the
grimarillion
and it includes material in it that is
going to be the basis of some of these
successor shows so
maybe we should get it out first before
the shows
and they agreed so they said yeah that
finish that one
and and then go back to wins of winter
so i sat down to finish that when i
polished all of the material i'd written
i expanded a few
sidebars it starts with aegon the
conqueror and his two sisters conquering
aegon's conquest and it goes up to the
regency of the boy king aegon iii so
there are lots of dragons and battles
and betrayals
after the targaryens fled valeria and
settled on dragonstone in advance of the
doom
a number of them came and went um mostly
their eyes still gazed east toward essos
but as the years pass and son succeeded
father and brother
succeeded brother um they began to take
more interest in the
affairs of westeros and aegon
finally decided to take over westeros
and unify the seven kingdoms that
existed at the time under a single rule
there is a lot of speculation that
in some sense he saw what was coming 300
years later
and wanted to unify the seven kingdoms
to be better prepared
for the threat that he eventually saw
coming
from the north the threat that we're
dealing with in
a song of ice and fire larrion the black
dread
he is the oldest and largest of the
targaryen dragons he's the only one
born in valeria when the targaryens fled
valeria before the doom
they brought i believe i say five
dragons with them
uh one by one those dragons died
on dragonstone um only belarion
survived past the conquest and to be the
the leading and most powerful dragon of
the age
so he's gigantic and old
and difficult to master or tame
he was aegon's dragon aegon the dragon
aegon the conqueror
the founder of the whole targaryen
dynasty
jaharis the conciliator the old king
was the longest reigning
of the targaryen monarchs he took the
crown when he was
14 years old and held it i believe for
55 years and alison was his sister
and his wife theirs was a
a great romance if you'll accept that an
incestuous relationship can be a great
romance
and they were for most of their reigns
they were they were partners they
worked together uh i mean jahiris ruled
but alessan had an immense amount of
influence over him and
on number of occasions he took her
advice or passed
laws that that she urged
you know i'm notorious for my love of
gray characters
and one of the greatest characters in
the entire westeros is damon targaryen
the rogue prince
uh we we took one of the sidebars and
made a separate story out of it the
rogue prince
damon is the younger brother of king
viserys the first
for a time he was the heir to the throne
when viserys had no children
and then viserys started having children
and he stopped being the heir to the
throne he's a notorious bad boy
a rogue in every sense of the word he
was a rival
for viserys sister and his own niece
rhaenyra
and then later he became the husband of
rhaenyra he switches sides several times
you never know what side he's going to
come down on
he's a very colorful and unpredictable
character
and i think he has to rank up there as
my favorite
i have i have a lot of affection for
mushroom well mushroom is a
is a dwarf and uh but he's not a
well-born one like tyrion he's
he's a dwarf of lowly birth who's
the the fool at in the court during
uh the events leading up to and during
much of the dance of the dragons and
this aftermath
he's a jester so mushroom is is a dwarf
but he's of the clever sort he's and
and he's an observer and he's the
testimony of mushroom
um this is uh this book's not actually
written by me you see it's written by
archmaester gildane of the citadel
and he's writing a history and like
anyone writing history he has to go back
to primary sources
and i had a lot of fun with that because
when he gets to the dance of dragons he
has a number of primary sources but
three of them are most major he has he
has grand master or wiles official court
records
he has the septon who was
kept the the sept in king's landing
and the red keep uh who of course is a
is a religious figure
so he interprets everything as the will
of the gods and what was a sin and what
wasn't the same
and he has mushroom who was
semi-illiterate
and couldn't actually write anything but
who told his story
um in later years to uh to a
equivalent of a monk who wrote it all
down and mushroom story of course is
always the most scandalous
girl-less filthy version of events
all of which had to do with people
betraying each other and poisoning each
other and
having similar type fun and sleeping in
places they shouldn't sleep
and all of that i love the idea since
this was a fake history
i didn't want to tell it as an
omniscient
historian setting down this is what
actually happened
i love the idea of telling it as a
historian in world
who's trying to figure out what happened
but he's looking about his primary
sources
and he's finding contradictory accounts
modern historian or someone like
archbishop gildane
has to sort through these stories
these contradictory stories and decide
which he believes and which he doesn't
believe
and i had a lot of fun being able to
tell you know
mushrooms accounts which are probably
all turned up to 37
and then the dollar accounts but i
didn't have to just stick to the dollar
account so i could give all three
and that was a great deal of fun
i this book only goes up to the regency
of aegon and ends when aegon iii
actually reaches man and takes control
so i have his reign to cover
which includes the death of the last
dragons although aegon the third is
called the dragon bane
there are still three or four dragons
kicking around when he takes the crown
and there are none by the time he's over
so
that one thing i was going to cover why
and what happens there and some of the
troubles and rebellions of his reign
and then ultimately his children who are
fairly interesting i mean he has
ultimately
five one of whom is
theron the first a young dragon who
conquers dorne
uh and he's a 14 year old alexander the
great kind of
hero king figure uh but he dies young
and then his
his brother bailor takes over and baylor
is
a very religious very he's more of a st
louis kind of figure um a little extreme
in his
religiosity and among other things he he
uh imprisons his three sisters in
luxurious imprisonment in the red keep
the maidenhall but he doesn't like them
like walking around
court because they tempt him i'll tell
their stories and i'll tell baylor's
story
and then after him will we get a brief
a brief reign of viserys
the second um and then
viserys son aegon the fourth egg on the
unworthy takes over and he's a
a very colorful figure himself i
obviously drew on henry the eighth for
him you know
henry the eighth had six wives aegon the
unworthy had nine mistresses and they
were all exist in my head i know who
they all were and what happened to each
of them and who was
who had their head chopped off and who
uh you know had affairs and who did what
so there's a lot of cool material that
and then you get into the blackfyre
rebellions
which were five i've referred to them
frequently
so i'll get all the details on the
blackfire rebellions and
ultimately we'll get up to the the mad
king and robert's rebellion
and wow that's where i'll draw it to a
[Music]
close
you